so now let's our powerful framework for
machine learning and then are accessible
for Mathematica so the recent popularity
has come from combination of things
whether it's from new techniques the
expansion and the amount of available
trading data
cheaper and faster processes
particularly GPUs they're really used in
production by large companies and for
computer vision speech-to-text ranking
and various other tasks the NIA new
electrochromic mathematic 11 provides a
construction kit for trading your own
networks so the things I'm going to
cover are how inputs to a net are coded
as tensors what layers operate on those
tensors harder compose lives or trading
data looks like our networks learn very
roughly the kinds of supervised learning
that you can do loss functions and a
worked example of training in practice
so your networks operate on numeric
tensors which are basically arrays of
numbers different lengths of tensor are
used depending on the application so
most common are vectors and matrices but
let's look at some examples there's some
several examples of tensors and what
kinds of data that can you be used to
represent vectors can be used to
represent points or encoding of discrete
classes so you can see these points
correspond to these two vectors and
these classes a B and C example labels
classes correspond to these one hot and
coded vectors matrices can represent
grayscale images and then three tenses
so generalization of matrices could be
replicas be used to represent images
with multiple color channels so red
green and blue in this case so they get
gated like an image into a network we
have to encode it as a tensor
Mathematica makes this easy with mesh
and coders so here we have an example of
encoding grayscale image here into a
tensor and another example of encoding a
class consisting of the labels dog cat
and frog these get encoded as unit
vectors in which exactly one vector
component is one and that as a zero the
net decoy
opposite to used on the output of a net
and it takes a tensor and converts it
back into something like an image or a
class leras are the building blocks of a
network most layers take a single input
tensor and produce an alpha tensor
crucially some layers contain parameters
that are modified during training in
order to specialize the network to a
given task and layers can be composed as
we'll see later so let's look at some
examples of layers dhoklas layers also
called fully cognizant zoom in quickly
so dr. slay is also called fully
connected layers in the literature are a
very common type of layer they contain a
weight matrix and a bias vector and they
effectively perform an affine
transformation of the input vector to
produce an output vector so it gives us
a visual representation of that the
weight and bias parameters are learned
during training the next up is an
element-wise layer it's a simpler kind
of layer that is often applied after a
dot plus layer it applies a
non-linearity to each element of the
important sir so element wise layers
have no learned parameters but you can
specify which non-linearity to apply and
here through the convolution layer is an
image oriented layer convolution layers
were the key innovation that made the
network's successful at computer vision
it involves a set of current its
convolved a set of kernels against the
input tensor which is a three tensor so
I'm just showing one channel of the
input image and you convolving it with
this kernel to produce each pixel of
output image these kernels are learned
during training it is possible to
visualize these kernels interestingly
some convolution networks learn kernels
that are reminiscent of the responses of
neurons in the human visual cortex so
here's some examples from a particularly
deep network
net is to chain together several layers
so that the output of each layer is used
as the input of the next net chain lets
you express this pattern once you've
bought a net chain you can probe the
individual layers interactively here's a
simple example of a net chain in action
it contains a
first layer a non-linearity and another
docklands layer the final output is a
vector of size 1 which we decode as a
single scalar value here we've plotted
the behavior of this net when the
weights are chosen randomly because
they're so common we can write dot plus
a nonlinear activation layers with a
kind of syntax sugar which you can see
here for more complex tasks we can use
net graph which lets you connect up
layers in more complex ways here I'm
showing a fairly complex object
recognition model called inception this
contains dozens of layers but most
graphs are much simpler than this this
is the kind of extreme case yeah I'm
going to show a very simple graph that
we will use to perform a common
operation at the start of the net and
then branch off from there to make two
separate our thoughts and here notice
that I've you
Netta port construct to name the two
upwards individually yeah I'm randomly
initializing this net because it
contains some parameters and we can
apply it to an input to see the outputs
of those those two ports yeah I'm
visualizing what those outputs do as a
function of the input training Network
is the process of showing the net lots
of input output examples and tuning the
learned parameters the net approximates
the correct output when given a
particular input more precisely this is
known as supervised learning we call the
set of examples of training data which
you will need to provide as the second
argument to net train I'll show that
data very much time so I'm not going to
cover the phenomenon of overfitting
which is the name for when a net
effectively memorizes input arc appears
instead of learning to generalize beyond
the training data it's sort of AI
equivalent of teaching to the test with
Mathematica 11 we provide a few
well-known data sets to experiment with
you can get access to these using the
function resource data which is also new
and 11 first that I'm showing here is M
List a database of handwritten digits
most common task is to predict the digit
just given the image the second is
support in a set of small images showing
objects in one of 10 categories again
just four samples of random the third is
a related data set called safar 100 set
of small images showing objects sorry
has two labels for each image learning
both tables at once is called multitask
learning you can find examples using all
of these data sets in the marketing
pages and the documentation of net rain
under applications one kind of
where's learnings known as regression in
this task the next job is to predict the
numeric value or tensor values from the
input the small data sets that's often
better to use the existing predict
function however neural networks can be
useful some neasha applications where
you have some prior knowledge of the
functions that will best approximates
your data or if you were to use more
exotic techniques like auto-encoders
classification involves trying to
predict a class variable which is an
output that takes one of a discrete set
of values object recognition for example
the classes could be strings like dog
cat and so on to do this you will need
to use the softmax layer to produce a
vector of probabilities using input from
some other stage of your net soft next
performs a kind of normalizing operation
as you can see here as I vary the inputs
to the softmax layer it kind of
normalizes them into probabilities that
all sum up to one once your net has
produced a probability vector it's
useful to use a net decoder to interpret
those probabilities here's a decoder
that interprets
so vector of length 3 as the
probabilities of the class's dog cat and
flock decoders can be attached to show
up to the author of an it and by default
give the most likely class so here
because it's the first class dog is the
most likely class and then here it's the
second one its highest said cat but if
we use a second argument to the decoder
we can access other useful properties
like the entropy of a particular
prediction or the top-end classes and
their probabilities the probability of
us visit a class like frog here so like
an encoder decoder can be attached to
the operative in it directly I'll show
you that later
before we can train the net we have to
define how to measure the performance in
it that's the job of loss functions most
functions take the production from the
net as well as the true value from the
training data and produce a loss which
is a measure of the error of the net as
you can see the loss decreases during
training typically it goes down quickly
and then starts to plateau as the
parameters of the net converge on their
final values most functions are layers
like any other layer unlike most layers
though they take two inputs one from the
net and one from the training data and
they produce a scalar value the loss the
right loss to use depends on the
application but luckily net train will
pick a loss function for you based on
the output of the net you can still
specify a loss using the third argument
of net train or by embedding your loss
directly in your network let's look at
example for regression problems
you'll usually want to use mean squared
loss but here I'll illustrate mean
absolute loss because it is easy to
visualize they're fairly similar mean
absolute loss measures the average
distance between the output of the net
and the true value this example shows
the input and target so there's the
input and there's the target and the
output
average distance between them as you can
see for classification problems the
situation is slightly more complex the
net produces a distribution in the form
of a probability vector yeah
the loss you'll want to use is known as
cross-entropy loss the technical
definition involves the average amount
of extra information you need to specify
the true class given the prediction of
network that this basic example shows
the idea we have a
we'll see vectors and here we have the
correct class so that's just an index
one two or three when the prediction
that signs a high probability to the
correct class in this case the first
class then the loss is low but if we say
that the second class is actually the
correct class then we get a much higher
loss because the network predicted the
lot the wrong path as you can tell for
these
examples minimizing the loss corresponds
to finding weights for the net that
cause it to correct the output as well
as possible so when training a network
that's really what what's really
happening is an optimization process the
trainer gate is split into small batches
typically a few dozen samples are in
each each batch net-net train will then
compute the error of the network in
reproducing the true output and from
that calculate a small change to make to
the learn parameters that will make the
network perform a bit better by applying
these changes again and again the net
converges and good values of these
parameters this is called gradient
descent we often talk with rounds which
also known as epochs around as one
entire traversal of the training data
depending on how much training data you
have around can take many seconds or
hours okay so let's do an example that
pulls everything together this example
shows a simple convolutional net being
trained to recognize objects in the cipa
10 data set first we obtain the obtain
the training data using the resource
data function then we create a decoder
to interpret the output of the net as
the probabilities of each of the 10
classes here the 10 classes and is the
decoder then we'll create an encoder to
take the images and turn them into three
tenses as the encoder in all setup the
network will use two stacks each
containing a convolution and
non-linearity and a pooling layer at
that point we'll have a smaller tensor
as you can see we started off with a
three by 32 by 32 3 tensor and then
after all these convolutions and fooling
us we end up with a much smaller 50 by
5x5 tensor so the spatial dimension is
reduced but the number of channels is
much higher these are sort of abstract
feature journals well flatten that
tensor into a vector with a flattened
layer effectively
going away the spatial information and
from that we'll use a two layer
perceptron and a softmax layer to
produce the final probabilities now
we're ready to Train I don't do this
here because it takes about seven
minutes on my laptop which doesn't have
an NVIDIA GPU now look we have a change
Network is the training process and a
screenshot for you we can use it to
classify a set of images so now I'm
feeding in five images and I'm getting
the five most likely classes for each
one as you'll notice next thread
automatically of inputs is quite a lot
more efficient than mapping the net over
this list and lastly we'll use a
property of the encoder of the final
decoder to obtain something more
interesting for a particular image not
the most likely class but the
probabilities of the top three classes
so in this case I did a terrible job but
thought that ostrich was either a truck
a dog or a deer so I'll show one more
thing which is once you've trained in it
you might want to make all all kinds of
measurements of how wallets it performs
so for that you use the classifier
measurements function this is a general
function that's used on the operative
classified but it can also be used on
nets and here are we feeding it test
data that the net wasn't exposed to
during training so it's a kind of fair
comparison it's not just memorizing the
inputs you can see that the accuracy
isn't particularly high this is quite a
simple net but it's possible to get
accuracy much higher than this so 65% of
examples were classified correctly we
can get a confusion matrix plot that
lets us understand which classes are
typically confused with other classes so
that bag more wrong this matrix tells
you all the correct classifications and
then rip diagonal things are
misclassifications and lastly we can
find particular miss classifications
that we might find you know hope helpful
to our intuition so here's an example of
all the tracks that are misclassified as
dogs okay so let's
a kind of whirlwind tour of the new net
functionality I try to give a very brief
introduction to the basic theory of how
they work and I've shown examples of
what they look like in Mathematica 11
there's a brief list of similar things
we're planning for subsequent versions
accord promised that any particular
feature will make it into 11.1 but we're
working hard on these by far the most
important feature here is support for
required nets which will allow you to
create nets that operate on sequential
data like text time series and video but
there other valuable features here like
most GP training alright that's the end
of my portion so first I'll take
questions and I guess we'll go to a
general chat session